[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
JJ BEHRENS: Howdy.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
Today we're talking
about YouTube API.
And we have Jeffrey Posnick
with us over in Hangouts.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Hi, guys.
JJ BEHRENS: Howdy.
And we have Danny Hermes from
the Google App Engine team.
Give it up, Danny.
Aw!
So today we're going to talk
about Party Playlist Picker.
And when I first came to Google,
before Google+ was
launched, we wanted to build
something that integrated the
YouTube APIs with Google+.
And so Jeffrey Posnick and I
decided that we should build
something cool, a nice mashup
on Google App Engine in
Python, mashing up the YouTube
APIs with the Google+ APIs.
DANNY HERMES: All the things
I like to hear.
JJ BEHRENS: I know, isn't it?
Yeah, it was pretty sweet.
And I'm definitely in my
comfort zone in Python.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
JEFFREY POSNICK: It
was a mega mashup.
JJ BEHRENS: Mega mashup.
And then it's like I kept on
going to all these different
hackathons.
And I was like, oh,
HTML5 hackathon?
I could do that.
So yeah, we had a great
time coding it.
And so today we're going
to talk about the app.
We're going to talk a little bit
about what it does, how it
does it, how it works with
Google App Engine.
Danny's going to tell
us we suck.
DANNY HERMES: That's
why I'm here.
JJ BEHRENS: He was like, dude,
what are you doing?
There's so many better
ways to do that.
And then we're going to
peek at the code.
And so it's going to
be a good time.
So, Jeffrey, you want to
start us off, show us
what the app can do?
JEFFREY POSNICK:
Sure thing, OK.
First of all, what I wanted to
make clear is that what JJ and
I worked on is an open-source
project, and the code is
freely available for
folks to use.
We have a link to the source
code on a blog post that we
have up announcing Party
Playlist Picker.
So if you go to
apiblog.youtube.com,
you can find that.
And I also wanted to make it
clear that this project is
something that's separate from
the official YouTube Google+
Hangout app, and that Hangout
app has some similar features.
But what we're talking about
today and what we're showing
off is something completely
separate.
So please don't confuse
the two.
JJ BEHRENS: And I would say we
came up with the idea first.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I am
not raising that
point, but fair enough.
Yeah, and as JJ mentioned, we
had a really good time coding
this and did a lot of stuff
via collaborative--
I guess, actually VNC pair
programming coast to coast.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
That was kind of crazy.
You're in New York.
I'm in San Francisco.
We were working two
hours a day coding
this in our 20% time.
And we didn't do any
of this in person.
We did this completely
over Google Hangouts
with stuff like that.
At some point, we were
doing screen sharing.
At some point, I was logged in
to your machine, and we were
editing at the same--
pair programming remotely
worked out really well.
DANNY HERMES: Wow.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, you were
sending emails for me.
You were taking care
of my work while I
wasn't paying attention.
And I appreciated that.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, this
is not true.
JEFFREY POSNICK: That
being said, this is
the fruits of labor.
So hopefully, you guys can
see the screen that I'm
sharing right now.
Both JJ and I are engineers,
I guess, first and
UI designers second.
So please pardon the spartan
user interface.
JJ BEHRENS: What are you trying
to say about my design
skills, Jeffrey?
DANNY HERMES: I've seen them.
I'll agree.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I'm trying to
say Helvetica is classic.
There's nothing wrong
with that.
So let's show off the way the
actual app goes and then run
through some of features.
Then we'll talk more about how
we built it, after folks have
had a chance to try it out.
So as all good YouTube API and
Google API integrations go,
this starts with OAuth
2 login flow.
I think the way I'm sharing my
screen, you might have a
little trouble seeing the actual
window that's going to
appear when click on Login.
Or no, OK.
You can see that.
So I'm going to log in.
That's my account.
And I'm going to enter my
two-step verification code as
all people should do.
I'm signed up for that.
And I'm going to be asked
whether I would like to grant
access to Party Playlist Picker
to manage my YouTube
account and know who
I am on Google.
So this is an example of using
two OAuth 2.0 scopes at once
to access my YouTube API
data and access some
Google+ data as well.
And I do trust Party Playlist
Picker, so I
will click Allow Access.
And after this login step, I'll
be redirected back to
this, again, somewhat spartan
but functional screen.
And at this point, I see a list
of all the playlists.
And these are real YouTube
playlists on the back end.
These are playlists
I've created using
Party Playlist Picker.
So a little bit earlier, I
created My New Playlist.
But I'm going to walk you
through the whole flow of
creating a new playlist
from scratch.
So in this case, enter Name.
Developers Live, So I'm going to
Create a new playlist, and
that's the first step in the
flow of using the app.
And I'm taken to this screen.
I am the only Partygoer right
now, which is kind of the
story my life.
But I'm going to make it look a
little bit more interesting.
I'll invite JJ and Danny to
collaboratively edit this
playlist along with me.
So we're just making it so
the standard Google+
Share button here.
And I'm going to--
"Hey, guys.
Want to join the party?" So the
idea might be I'm going to
have some party or some sort of
gathering later and have a
bunch of people attending.
And I'd like people to be able
to create a playlist of videos
that they want to show
during the party.
That's the basic idea.
So I'm going to add JJ.
I'm going to Daniel Hermes.
And I'm going to click Share.
So what this is doing is
actually creating a post in
their Google+ streams.
And it has link-back to a unique
URL that allows them to
come in and edit that
shared playlist.
So that's the type of ACL that
we're using in this case.
Anybody who has that URL
could come in and
edit that shared playlist.
So hopefully, JJ and Danny
saw that and will
get a chance to join.
In the meantime, I'm going to
start adding some videos.
So we have a nice little
search box there.
And this all is making YouTube
API calls on the back end
using the standard YouTube
API Python library.
So I see Shannon and JJ
Behrens just joined.
If I want to know a little bit
more about him, I think I can
click on that and go to
his Google+ profile.
So we're integrated with Google+
in terms of getting
profile information
and also sharing.
That's our vector for
sharing things.
So I'm going to add a
couple of videos.
I always like videos
that have me in the
thumbnail, as that one does.
So I'm going to add that.
We have a little bit a jQuery
UI, or maybe that's just
standard jQuery magic there
for doing some of those
transitions.
And sometimes you might not be
quite as familiar with some of
these videos that show up
in the search results.
So we have a way of previewing
the video right inline by
clicking on the Play button.
This uses the standard
YouTube iFrame embed.
It just gives you an example
of what kind of--
ooh!
Oh no!
So you might have just
missed that.
But JJ just added a video
to the playlist.
JJ is now actually in
the Dart world.
He's transitioned
off of YouTube.
So I think he's competing with
me a little bit and tying to
add some Dart videos.
And there's another one.
So I'm going to say, all
right, that's fine.
I'm going to actually
be generous.
I'm going to move JJ's Dart
video to the top of the
playlist here because I do want
to see the "Introduction
to Dart."
DANNY HERMES: What kind of party
is this with no music?
JJ BEHRENS: I know.
We're getting there.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
And we want to be careful about
what we're broadcasting
over the Hangout also.
I think that Seth is going to
be fine with us showing him
talking about Dart
in the Hangout
right now, for instance.
So I don't anticipate too much
of a problem with that.
So OK.
So this gives you an idea of
how people collaboratively
edit playlists.
And if you've noticed, what
happened is that when JJ added
a video to the playlist, without
my page having to
refresh or anything, it just
seamlessly appeared in the
list of the videos
that are there.
So we're actually using the
channels they've got-- which
Danny's going to talk a little
bit about later--
to open a connection to the
server and to just have the
server effectively push those
updates down to us.
And we're doing something kind
of nifty with the HTML that we
get pushed from the server
and doing a diff using a
JavaScript diff library and
trying to identify what the
new videos are.
So we're not getting the
deltas from the server.
We're actually getting that
whole chunk of HTML compared
to our local chunk of HTML.
And anything that the diff
algorithm tells us is new, we
animate Showing.
JJ BEHRENS: I like the
diff functionality.
Did you also show the
drag-and-drop functionality?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, so we
have drag and drop for
reordering.
We also have drag and
drop for just adding
things to the playlist.
And that's going to end up--
I think somebody might have
removed something from the
playlist in the meantime.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I did.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, so can
see the things getting
updated as we go.
So we have a nice little
playlist now.
The type of parties that I
throw, we normally just
discuss the YouTube API.
I don't know how the audience is
going to necessarily react
to the Dart video at the end.
But we have about an
hour plus of the
YouTube API concept there.
So I think people are probably
going to be zonked out at that
point and not really notice
that we're sneaking in 50
minutes of JJ talking about
Dart in Glasgow.
JJ BEHRENS: And now we're
going to talk about AS3!
JEFFREY POSNICK: Ooh!
That's always interesting.
So once the playlist is fully
assembled, you could view the
playlist on YouTube.
You could see those videos
are now in a
real YouTube playlist.
You could play them from here.
You could share the playlist.
You could get the embed code
from the playlist straight
from YouTube.
So you're ready for
your party.
And that's the basic idea.
JJ BEHRENS: You could also
watch individual
videos on the site.
So that was a nice little
light-box effect
that you did for that.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yep, just
right over there.
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
That's pretty cool.
JEFFREY POSNICK: So if you're
looking for examples of doing
that exact thing, for instance,
where you have a
thumbnail for videos--
So this is just a thumbnail
and has a little bit of
JavaScript and CSS to put that
Play button over there.
If you're looking for an example
of how to do that,
feel free to take our code.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm going to go
offline to show you what it
looks like when someone
has edited it in the
past but goes offline.
So we've got state
going on there.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yep.
So you keep track of who's
currently editing and
everybody who's edited
in the past.
Yeah, JJ, anything
else major about
the app that I neglected?
I guess the Manage
Playlists page.
That's just having the initial
page over there where we could
go and choose different
playlists.
JJ BEHRENS: No.
I think you got it.
Yeah.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cool.
JJ BEHRENS: That's cool.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
So as we mentioned, this
is built on top
of Python App Engine.
And we have Danny in the studio,
who is very much an
App Engine expert.
And I think you wanted to talk a
little bit about some of the
sort of technology that we used
and some more general
Python App Engine technology and
how you can integrate with
other Google APIs.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
So why don't we have
a talk with Danny.
And Danny can tell us where
we're doing it wrong.
And then we'll show some code.
DANNY HERMES: So in addition
to being on the App Engine
team, I've also worked
a lot on the
Google API client libraries.
When we're talking about
Python, there are two
libraries that are
the main ones.
We have the GData
Python client.
And we have the Google
API Python client.
And these libraries are actually
targeting different
families of APIs.
So Google APIs that are a bit
older, including the YouTube
API, were based on a GData
standard, which was a Google
Data standard.
JJ BEHRENS: We're keeping
it old school.
DANNY HERMES: We're keeping
And this newer library targets
some newer discovery-based
APIs that Google offers, APIs
that have an entire JSON
discovery document that
totally explains
what that API does.
JJ BEHRENS: And that's what
we're switching to right now.
We first announced that at
Google I/O. And so we've got
some support, and we're
working on more.
DANNY HERMES: Certainly.
So the reason I bring up these
two libraries is because both
of them are actually being
used in this application.
This is one of these things
that I scolded JJ about.
So OAuth 2 is a relatively
new spec, right?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: So we've had specs
as a moving target as we
understand security and try to
refine the model better for
usability for end users.
So when they originally wrote
it, there was no OAuth 2
support in the GData Python
Client Library.
But since the YouTube API is a
GData API, they needed to use
the GData API.
So they do the OAuth 2 stuff
with the Google API Python
client and the actual
API calls with the
GData Python client.
JJ BEHRENS: We like
it both ways.
DANNY HERMES: So a few
things I want to say.
One, with the Google
API Python client,
there are nice things.
If you're familiar with Python,
there's a concept of a
decorator, which you put above
a function or a method
declaration.
And it wraps the method,
essentially redefining that
method, and so doing, actually
gives it more functionality.
So the Google API Python
Client Library gives a
decorator, which allows
you to define a
simple response handler.
So if your web page that you're
visiting has a Get
request handler, you can
actually wrap their handler,
and it'll handle all the Auth
stuff that you need to do.
And you don't really have
to worry about it.
JJ BEHRENS: That is a big win.
That was a huge savings
in terms of
making our life easier.
Because all that OAuth 2 token
management stuff, it's like it
took care of it for us.
It automatically managed the
tokens in the datastore.
And there was a little bit of
work that we had to do.
But by and large, the decorator
saved our bacon.
DANNY HERMES: Yup.
And that decorator, I will
honestly say it's probably
easier to use than the OAuth
2 support in the
GData Python client.
But if you're looking to
integrate a GData YouTube
application, there is OAuth
2 support in that library.
There was a blog post last
November, actually, from Alain
Vongsouvanh on the
Google Apps team.
And we'll try to provide a link
in the description of
this YouTube video to
that blog post.
But it describes the
general flow.
You set up with a credentials
object.
You get a URL to direct your
users to, to actually accept
your app to have permissions to
access their data, and then
they get redirected back
to your application.
And from there, the actual
credentials object is either
deserialized from some
datastore or maybe
deserialized within memory,
depending on what type of
application you're writing.
And you can actually finish
the authorization flow.
And a lot of the actual details
of the spec are
abstracted away from
you by the library.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
So I should just mention a
little bit more since we're a
little bit down in the weeds.
From a high-level perspective,
the goal is we have this
playlist on YouTube, and we want
to manage the playlist
via this third-party
application.
And so OAuth 2 is what makes it
possible for me to use this
application and manage someone
else's playlist.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
And not only that, it also
allows you to retrieve video
data, retrieve these
thumbnails and the
descriptions, the titles,
and these other things.
You're able, with the API, to
get the data that you'd expect
to be able to get when you
actually go to youtube.com.
JJ BEHRENS: So there's something
clever going on here
that maybe you might not
have thought about.
And that's that Jeffrey
was the one
who created the playlist.
And yet I'm using my computer
to manage his playlist.
And if know the YouTube API
well enough, that is not
something the YouTube
API gives you.
It doesn't give you the ability
to manage other
people's playlists.
I bet you're wondering
how we did that.
DANNY HERMES: "Clever"
is one word.
"Trustworthy" may
be another word.
But that's maybe all I'll
say about that.
JJ BEHRENS: I should
explain it, though.
The way it works is
when Jeffrey--
Jeffrey logs in and gives the
application access to his
OAuth 2 tokens.
And then when I'm managing his
playlist, the application does
things to his playlist
on my behalf.
And so it is safe insofar as
the app itself is safe.
And of course, you're
trusting the app.
I mean, that's what OAuth 2 is
about, is saying this app is
trustworthy.
And so it just so happens that
I'm the one initiating actions
to Jeffrey's playlist, which
is kind of a neat idea.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And we are
using a unique URL to control
access to folks who have access
to this, which is not
necessarily the best approach.
It was the most workable
approach that JJ and I found
that allowed us to integrate
with Google+ the
way we wanted to.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
And people who are maybe
interested in a more robust
approach may consider, rather
than having somebody else
controlling the owner's account,
maybe having some
third-party account.
I don't know if the terms of
service of YouTube allow this.
But it is another model rather
than having some owner have a
decentralized place where
playlists are owned.
But anyway, moving on from that,
I want to talk about two
other App Engine features
that were used.
Maybe two and a half,
let's say.
The first is the Channel API,
not the Channels API, as both
Jeff and JJ constantly say.
But the Channel API allows
you to create
channels for message passing.
It's effectively a nice wrapper
that creates a one-way
socket between your client that
is actually accessing the
application via the web and
the application itself.
JJ BEHRENS: Can we just
call this "real time"?
DANNY HERMES: No.
We're going to call it the
Channel API, which
is the name of it.
And so that unique URL that
Jeff was talking about
actually gives the data
about the channel
itself for the client.
And so a few things that you're
able to do, so one, in
order to use it-- it's
really simple--
there is--
in the very top of the head
section of the HTML for the
page, there is a bit of
JavaScript that comes
pre-loaded with the application
that handles all
the code that you need
and puts it in
the global name space.
JJ BEHRENS: It's way simpler
than when I tried to do it
myself using Erlang.
I'll say that.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, I'm going
to guess anything with App
Engine is probably simpler than
Erlang, but maybe not.
And once you have this code
loaded, you actually open a
channel between the client and
the application to pass
messages and receive messages.
And you just need to define
a few handlers on it.
So you define a handler for it
if an error occurs, if a
socket opens, if a socket
closes, and then, of course,
if a message gets passed
from the application.
And I mentioned it's
a one-way channel.
So there's no way via this
channel to send messages back
to the application.
However, since it's a web
application, via Ajax, post
messages, and other things, you
can still send messages to
the application.
And you can still--
via some form of identity that
you have with your users, you
can still take that identity,
and then whatever they do in
that post handler send the diff
or send the full payload
of that playlist back
to your users.
And that's what's actually
happening.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, so
we're using this in
two different places.
One is we're using this to keep
track of who's currently
editing the web page.
So you could see who all the
other partygoers are.
And the second thing is we're
using this to show you the
updates to the playlist
in real time.
And I would have to say since
I've coded web stuff in
everything you could imagine
from AS3 to .net, like weird
stuff, this is the easiest way
that I've ever seen for doing
real-time comment type stuff.
It really pays off using App
Engine to just have this stuff
work without having to architect
it from scratch.
DANNY HERMES: I would certainly
agree with that.
JJ BEHRENS: You should.
You're on the App Engine team.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yes.
I just want to point
one thing out.
We are guilty of using it maybe
not entirely as it was
intended in that we're using
it as a broadcast mechanism
for a bunch of different users,
potentially a lot of them.
DANNY HERMES: That's certainly
how it was intended.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
I just want to make sure
because I got into some
discussions with some of the App
Engine team members, not
you necessarily, but some other
folks, about wanting to
have one API call to send
messages to 50 people at once.
And I gathered that that was not
entirely according to spec
to do that.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah,
50 might be a lot.
But certainly the intent is to
be able to use it, to be able
to have some sense of
collaboration, like playing
tic-tac-toe is the seminal
example in the documentation.
JJ BEHRENS: So are you trying to
say that this is sufficient
for my-sized parties,
but maybe not for
Shakira-sized parties.
DANNY HERMES: Maybe.
Maybe we stop at Shakira.
So the last one, one and a half
features of App Engine I
want to talk about, I want to
give a bit of a preamble about
what App Engine.
So for people who don't know,
it's a platform as a service.
And what this means on the
surface is that you don't
actually have control of the
system running it or even a
virtual machine.
It's even higher level than
a virtual machine.
And you upload application
code according to some
specification in some libraries
that are included.
And you run your code
from there.
So it's like I said, it's
even higher level
than a virtual machine.
However there's still
a concept of memory.
You still have local memory.
And you still have
persistent disk.
And they're not really the same
thing, RAM versus hard
drive, right?
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
DANNY HERMES: And so with that
in mind, I want to talk about
the ways this application is
persisting data or maybe not
persisting data.
So some of the things like the
actual identifier for the
channels to send messages, well,
you could imagine you'd
have two users who don't know
anything about each other and
haven't invited each other,
but they have some catchy
playlist name that
they want to use.
So the playlist itself is
not a global identifier.
So you need to have some other
sort of global identifier.
So this application uses
something called memcache.
And it's exactly what
it sounds like.
It sort of adheres to a memcache
spec, which is sort
of agnostic of App Engine.
And using memcache, you can
actually partially persist
data in memory.
But it doesn't actually make
it to persistent disk.
And so they're able to use
memcache for things like
caching the randomized token or
the randomized identifier
for the channels so that, like
I said, if you have two
different groups of people, two
different parties making
playlists with the same name,
you don't have a collision so
that they're sending the wrong
messages to the wrong clients.
JJ BEHRENS: And we're also
using memcache to cache
Google+ responses for very
short amounts of time.
I know they wouldn't want
us to cache them for
long amounts of time.
But, for instance, we want to
show the user's profile
picture on every single
page load.
We don't want to make it a hit
to the Google+ servers every
single page load.
And so we cache that for very
short amounts of time.
DANNY HERMES: Right.
And memcache--
I don't know that you guys
are doing this in your
application--
it does allow you to specify
when you add something the
cache that you'd like to
invalidate it after a certain
amount of time.
Just like with RAM, it's
not guaranteed to be
there all the time.
That's why I say it's
not persistent.
So it is something that
sort of transient.
This is the word.
I'm stealing this from JJ from
our discussion earlier.
You can expect it to
be there maybe some
portion of the time.
But expecting something you put
in memcache to be there
all the time is a bad way
to design applications.
However, given things like many
clients accessing the
same data, reading directly from
memory rather than going
to some external datastore or
some external persistent
memory actually reduces the
amount of I/O and can greatly
reduce the amount of latency
in your responses.
JJ BEHRENS: We don't like
slow apps at Google.
That's just how we roll.
DANNY HERMES: And so the tiny
half-feature I wanted to talk
about is that they're actually,
I believe, storing
credentials that they don't
even know they're doing.
But the decorator itself, this
OAuth Decorator, stores
credentials in the datastore
for Google App Engine.
And the datastore is a
persistent datastore.
And calls to the datastore take
sometimes much longer,
but certainly a little bit
longer than calls to memcache.
And I'm not going to say much
else, other than that
datastore is a NoSQL database.
You can define arbitrary
objects in it.
JJ BEHRENS: The largest
NoSQL database.
DANNY HERMES: Exactly.
The largest NoSQL database
in the world.
JJ BEHRENS: We also store
a couple other
things in the datastore.
We store the list of
people who have
ever edited a playlist.
That doesn't go away.
We always remember who's
edited a playlist.
We also keep track of our
internal identifier for the
title for the playlist.
There's actually a few different
metadata-type things
that we wrap around
the playlist.
DANNY HERMES: Things that can't
disappear if memcache
decides to crap out on you.
JJ BEHRENS: Yes, that's right.
And then, a lot of the most
interesting pieces of data
aren't stored in App
Engine at all.
But they're actually stored in
YouTube via the YouTube API.
So the playlist itself
lives in YouTube.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And I really
like that model, where we
don't have to worry about
keeping things in sync and
what the authoritative
version is.
We know that whatever's
in YouTube is the
authoritative version.
And that's what gets
pushed down to
users who are connected.
And they are obviously really
elegant algorithms for trying
to do that sort of thing.
We're taking more of a brute
force approach, but it seems
to work for us.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm all about
the brute force.
That way it doesn't mess up.
Jeffrey, do you have any other
comments about our storing in
memcache versus Datastore
versus YouTube?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah,
just to build on
something that Danny mentioned.
I really, really liked what the
Google API Python Client
Library was doing with the
decorator and automatically
persisting those OAuth 2 tokens
for us in the datastore.
OAuth 2 kind of gets a
reputation as being something
that is complicated.
And I usually tell people,
if you think OAuth 2 is
complicated, you never used
OAuth 1, which has
its own set of issues.
But the client library from
Python, in particular-- and I
know that our other languages
have varying degrees of
support, as well.
But I really, really found it
very easy integrating with
OAuth 2 in a Python App
Engine application.
It couldn't have been simpler.
You don't have to worry about
keeping track of even doing
the refreshes.
The client library handles the
token refreshes for you, which
is amazing.
So a really great experience.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I agree
with all of that.
I should mention a little
bit about testing.
We kind of whipped this
out as a prototype.
And so we didn't actually
write test in this.
We did code-review everything.
Everything's well documented.
Literally, we code-reviewed
everything.
But we left out the testing.
But some of you might have seen,
I did a tutorial for
Google I/O called "Using Ruby on
Rails and YouTube APIs for
Building Educational Apps." And
even though that's a Ruby
talk instead of a Python talk,
one thing I really like about
the talk is I explain how to
do full-on test-driven
development with web APIs.
How do you deal with an API
that you might not fully
understand?
How can you possibly
mock that out?
And especially towards the end
of the video, I show how to,
within a debugger, make a
request, get the response,
grab it, store it away, and then
set up mocks so that the
next time you do that request
from within your tests, you
get the same actual,
completely legitimate response.
And so you could do full-on
test-driven development,
making the entire request,
integration-type testing even
with the web API.
So I recommend that tutorial.
I was in it, so, of course,
I recommend it.
DANNY HERMES: Certainly.
JJ BEHRENS: But I know that
Jeffrey and I, we definitely
used those tricks where we were
making requests, dumping
ourselves into a debugger, and
then playing around, which is
a very Pythonic thing to do.
You're playing around with the
data, getting a feel for it,
and then writing the code that
you're going to write, but
inside the debugger, and then
copying and pasting
that into the code.
That works really well.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cool.
Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: So anything else
we could think of that we
implemented in this that was
kind of interesting?
JEFFREY POSNICK: I don't know.
I think that it's just great
that there's a decent body of
both JavaScript code using
jQuery pretty heavily and
Python code for folks
to look through.
It's all open source.
If you see something in the app
that might be useful to
your own project, feel
free to borrow.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
All right.
So why don't we take
a look at the code?
And since I promised to do that,
let me do that briefly.
And I'm going to go to
this Google Hangout.
And I'm going to share
my screen.
Desktop, Share Selected,
and OK.
Great.
So here's Party Playlist
Picker.
This is on code.google.com/
p/party-playlist-picker.
And I'm going to browse
the source.
So this is in Git.
We have a top-level Python
package called playlistpicker.
We have a directory called
static for all
of our static files.
And then we have a directory
called third-party, for all of
our third-party Python
libraries, such as apiclient,
atom, gdata, httplib2,
oauth2client, and template.
DANNY HERMES: You might
want to zoom in a bit.
JJ BEHRENS: Oop, thanks.
Thank you.
OK?
DANNY HERMES: There you go.
JJ BEHRENS: So in static,
we have CSS images.
And we have this big chunk
of jQuery code.
And it looks like jQuery code,
a bunch of nested functions
and a bunch of the
dollar sign.
DANNY HERMES: Callback hell.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, yeah.
And callbacks all
over the place.
And we used--
what do you call the basic
framework that App
Engine uses in Python?
It's App Client?
I forget the name of it.
What is this?
DANNY HERMES: App.yaml, the
application configuration?
JJ BEHRENS: WebApp.
I'm sorry.
WebApp is the basic framework
in Python.
DANNY HERMES: I see, yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: So this is
a WebApp application.
It's not Django.
But we structured it in a way
that would be very, very
familiar to Django programmers
or Ruby on Rails programmers.
So inside this package,
playlistpicker, we have
handlers, which handle
a specific page.
We have templates.
And then we have utils.
And so each page generally
has a handler.
Each page generally
has a template.
And then the utils is
a bunch of stuff for
all that other stuff.
We also have a routes file,
where we import things.
This is a little bit
brute force-ish.
But we map out all of our urls
and all the handlers.
So that's pretty
straightforward.
DANNY HERMES: Pretty Django.
JJ BEHRENS: Pretty Django-ish,
except for we're not doing any
automatic stuff.
But that worked out all fine.
So in the utils directory, we
created files for dealing with
channels, friendlist,
googleplus, memcache,
web-related stuff and
YouTube stuff.
And since this is a YouTube
show, I should point out we
needed functions for creating
YouTube service, preparing
playlists, parsing durations in
seconds-- you know, you do
a little bit of random parsing
when you're dealing with API--
writing a playlist, fetching
a feed and
entries, and so forth.
And so all the YouTube-related
stuff, it's in there.
You could look at it
if you need to.
So let me jump over
to the handlers.
We have handlers for all the
different things like the
playlist handler, removing
the playlist
entry, the search handler.
The Ajax is calling back
to various handlers.
And just like Django
and Ruby on Rails?
DANNY HERMES: Now, do you have
a separate module for every
single handler?
JJ BEHRENS: I think sometimes
we-- yeah.
Yeah, we do.
DANNY HERMES: Wow.
Wow.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
I like to keep things
a little bit small.
I don't know.
My brain's not overly large.
DANNY HERMES: For serving
static content, though?
I mean--
JJ BEHRENS: For static
content, it's
in the static directory.
DANNY HERMES: Oh, OK.
There you go.
No handler needed.
JJ BEHRENS: No handler needed.
All the handlers have a
parent class, which is
in this base handler.
And this takes care of a bunch
of interesting things.
Also, it sets up our decorator
that you were talking about.
It takes care of a bunch of
authentication-type stuff.
One interesting thing is that
there's the GData API and then
the newer types of API.
And when you have an
authorization error, they
throw different exceptions.
DANNY HERMES: Different
status codes?
JJ BEHRENS: No, not different
status codes.
But the libraries itself
will throw a
different Python exception.
DANNY HERMES: Ah, I see.
I see.
JJ BEHRENS: And so we set up a
global exception handler to
handle both of those and follow
them through the same
place to take care of, for
instance, if someone's OAuth 2
token is expired.
And so setting up a global
exception handler is a really,
really useful thing
to be able to do.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
And certainly, given the
support in those both
libraries now for OAuth 2, you
actually don't have to worry
about what or not a
token's expired.
JJ BEHRENS: Yes, yes.
But setting up a global
exception
handler comes in handy.
That is a tool that's
reusable.
DANNY HERMES: Certainly.
JJ BEHRENS: So here's the
editplaylisthandler.
It's pretty simple.
We have a Git.
We're making use of various
of those util modules.
We're setting up some
template parameters.
And then we're rendering
a template.
Let me show you what a
template looks like.
This is based on Django's
templating system.
And it looks fairly
straightforward.
If you've seen Django or if
you've seen Ruby on Rails,
none of the stuff is all
that unfamiliar.
There's one trick that we did
where every template can add
to the JavaScript head.
That's kind of nice because I
like having page-specific
JavaScript.
That's kind of nice.
And let me see.
I think I'm out of things
to talk about.
There's the code.
If you're interested in looking
at the code some more,
you could definitely
download it.
DANNY HERMES: Now, did
you guys use Python
2.5 or Python 2.7?
I think it was Python 2.5.
Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
JJ BEHRENS: This is before
Python 2.7 support was around.
We actually worked on this for
a surprisingly long time.
If you look at the code, it's
not a tiny amount of code.
I mean, it's not massive.
But we worked on this for
several quarters.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
Certainly.
So a quick note.
There are two different Python
runtimes that are supported in
App Engine.
And Python 2.5 was the very
first runtime for App Engine.
There are four now, including
both Python, Go, and Java.
And the Python 2.7 runtime does
not use Django as the
default templating system.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, is that right?
DANNY HERMES: But it's still
possible to use Django.
But there's a bit of
a difference there.
So for people who are used to
Python 2.7, all this you're
hearing about Django, it's
really the sort of
capabilities that came
out of the box.
Django was chosen as an
arbitrarily framework, which
was also easy to use.
But if there's anything Python
has a lot of, it's frameworks.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
I always say that to be a really
good Python programmer,
you have to do, really,
three things.
One is to write your own
templating language.
Then you have to write
your own framework.
And then you have to implement
Scheme in Python.
I mean, those are the bars.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
I'm apparently zero out of
three, a terrible Python
programmer.
JJ BEHRENS: Well, we're going
to fix that later.
So I think we're--
Jeffrey, did you have anything
else to add?
Did we lose Jeffrey?
I think we might have
lost Jeffrey.
Oh, I'm supposed to mention
the fact that not only is
Google hiring, but the YouTube
API team in Developer
Relations is hiring.
It's a busy life, but
it's a fun life.
DANNY HERMES: Oh,
it's great life.
Developer Relations is
probably the most fun
place in the world.
I would rather do this job
than be president.
President looks just
kind of stressful.
DANNY HERMES: Bar none,
I would rather do
this than be president.
JJ BEHRENS: Agreed.
Yes, especially since
I have horrible
skeletons in my closet.
Yes.
No, not really.
But anyway, thank you guys
for watching today.
If you guys stuck around
to the very end,
more kudos to you.
I think you guys are awesome .
And Danny, thanks a lot for
coming around today and
telling me how much
I suck in my app.
DANNY HERMES: My pleasure.
JJ BEHRENS: We will see
you guys next time.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, and check
out the description on YouTube
for some helpful links.
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
[MUSIC PLAYING]